[Musique]
c'est très difficile de s'exprimer quand
on
quand on a un lieu tellement cher
[Musique]
une relation
émotionnelle avec la médina la médina
c'est notre mémoire
[Musique]
quand je prends mon café je pense jamais
le prendre à l'extérieur souvent je
viens de la médina
de l'amour à profusion pour une cité qui
incarnait la puissance des siècles
durant une ville fortifiée et un port
plaque tournante du commerce avec
l'Afrique jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle
[Musique]
ici juif chrétien musulmans cohabitent
paisiblement depuis la nuit des temps
aujourd'hui la médina de Essaouira
joyeux du patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO
attire les touristes par dizaines de
milliers c'est aussi et surtout le cœur
d'une communauté
[Musique]
mais cette forteresse pourrait bientôt
avoir les pieds dans l'eau conséquence
des changements climatiques il se peut
que
ses amis trois enseignants à la retraite
la médina de sawira n'a plus aucun
secret
ils sont nés ici ils ont grandi ici et
ils passent maintenant une grande partie
de leur journée
dans ces rues autrefois habitées par des
Phéniciens des Romains et des Portugais
ils oublient la notion du temps il
papote avec les copains ils prennent le
café
[Musique]
pour Saïd perdre sa médina dorée serait
un grand choc qu'on j'ai perdu l'un de
nos parents
car ils savent que les infiltrations
d'eau et les inondations peuvent être
sans merci
ce quartier de la ville on a déjà été
victime les infiltrations
il y avait en plus des inondations qui
ont commencé en 1996 qui ont fait
beaucoup de familles qui sont déménagés
qui sont relongés
rappelle que les autorités n'ont pas eu
le choix d'exproprier les quelques 3000
résidents du quartier et de détruire les
maisons fragilisées
le quartier toute ma vie c'est un très
beau quartier d'ailleurs
comme ça ça fait mal au cœur
depuis quelques années l'état fait
d'importants travaux dans le port et
dans la médina ce qui permettra de
reconstruire cette portion de la ville
les plus jeunes aussi comme amine un
professeur de 33 ans craigne le pays
nous montre le Riyad où il est né
développés qui continuent d'exploiter
les énergies fossiles je crois qu'ils
sont faux dit de devenir des gens des
autres on peut avoir des alternatives
aux Pérol pourquoi l'utiliser pourquoi
l'extraire extraire du pétrole d'une
région qui est comme on dit
[Musique]
je suis un peu ému
le maire de sawira est conscient que la
préservation de la médina demandera
énormément de moyens
des efforts qui sont faits par les par
la ville par les autorités par les élus
malgré le peu de moyens qu'on a donc je
pense que la ville a besoin le Maroc
également a besoin d'être dans ce sens
taricotements voudrait bien offrir un
tour guidé de sa médina au grand
dirigeants des nations les plus
polluantes
qui vit c'est des petites mains vous
allez faire un tour dans la médina vous
allez voir vous allez vite comprendre
que ces gens là ne se soucient même pas
de ça là c'est la population la plus
menacée
donc moi je les emmènerai d'abord voir
est-ce que cette menace représente pour
pour leur vie pour leur famille les
petit
es mains
elle est toute inondée l'artisan avait
aucune idée que ça Medina était menacée
je suis désolé d'apprendre tout ça
j'ignorais tout de ces scénarios je ne
m'attendais pas à voir ce genre d'image
[Musique]
je ne peux pas vivre en dehors de la
médina même quand je voyage je n'ai
qu'une chose en tête revenir ici à la
médina non ça ça
[Musique]
si la médina de Essaouira n'est à nulle
sa situation est loin d'être unique
à moins d'un sérieux coup de barre pour
limiter les émissions de GES et des
forts concertés pour les protéger une
cinquantaine d'autres sites classés en
Afrique sont en péril menacées par une
dame nature qui s'affole
c'est un patrimoine national c'est un
bijoux c'est un patrimoine de l'humanité
[Musique]
des joyaux du patrimoine mondial mais
aussi des colosses au pied d'argile
[Musique]